تم التغريد على دونالد ترامب في الدقيقتين الماضيتين فقط أنهى
محادثتنا بالفعل بردك على هذا
كما ذكرت بقوة قبل أن
يقول وفقط للتأكيد على ما إذا كانت تركيا قد فعلت
أي شيء أعتبره بحكمتي العظيمة التي
لا مثيل لها -
الحدود التي سأدمرها تمامًا
وأمحوها من اقتصاد تركيا التي أقتبسها
بين قوسين قمت به قبل أن يتوجب عليهم ذلك
مع أوروبا والآخرون يراقبون
مقاتلي داعش وعائلاتهم التي
فعلتها الولايات المتحدة أكثر بكثير مما
كان يتوقعه أي شخص بما في ذلك
الاستيلاء على واحد.  مائة بالمائة من
خلافة داعش ، حان الوقت الآن
للآخرين في المنطقة لبعض الثروات العظيمة
لحماية
أراضيهم ، الولايات المتحدة رائعة وهذا
اقتراح لاذع إلى حد ما ، أليس الأمر يتعلق
بحكمتي العظيمة التي اعتبرها
خارجة عن المألوف  - حدود سأدمر
وأمحو اقتصاد تركيا تمامًا ، كما يقول
، لقد فعلت ذلك قبل
أن يتوجب عليهم ذلك مع أوروبا والآخرون
يراقبون مقاتلي داعش الأسرى
كتهديد  سيدي حسنًا ، جوهر الأمر هو
أنك تعلم أن مقاتلي داعش الأسرى
يجب تقديم الإرهابيين للعدالة
وقد رفض الأوروبيون أخذهم حتى
الآن لذا سيتحمل
المسؤولية عنهم ، فليست مسؤولية أي دولة بمفردها
بل تقع على عاتق الجميع
مسؤولية إحضار  نهاية لهذه
الحلقة الرهيبة في
التاريخ الحديث للشرق الأوسط
وسوريا ، أي داعش ، ولا يمكننا أن
نقول فقط أننا كمجتمع دولي
نفشل في تدمير
هذه الشبكة الإرهابية أعتقد أن
لدينا الوسائل للقيام بذلك  سنفعل ذلك
مع الأوروبيين الأمريكيين وغيرهم
لدعم الأقران والتنسيق ، وأعتقد أنه
إذا كان هناك ما يكفي من القانون والحكمة
والقيادة يمكننا بالتأكيد القيام بذلك ،
فسنعمل على وضع تفاصيل ذلك ، ولكن
مرة أخرى دعني أؤكد أن هذا ليس بأي حال من
الأحوال  الهجوم على أكراد سوريا أو
غزو أي جزء من سوريا
لم يكن أبدًا موضع
اهتمامنا بالنظر إلى مسار
عملنا وأعتقد أن أفعالنا حتى الآن
لقد فعلت تركيا بصوت أعلى بكثير
للشعب السوري
واللاجئين السوريين أكثر بكثير من أي دولة أخرى في
العالم وستواصل القيام بذلك من أجلهم